hi there today I want to talk about
learning the basics in a language we
always hear people say that that you
first have to learn the basics and you
have if you have the basics then you
have a solid foundation on which you can
then you know eventually learn to become
fluent it's very important to start by
learning the basics I disagree the best
way to learn the basics is the way I
have done with Ukrainian and what I will
then do for Polish and if I go to Dutch
for other languages first get exposed to
the language now I admit that it's
easier if you're into a related language
but even if you're an English speaker
learning Spanish it's close enough read
and listen the way I do on link I take
these lessons I look up save words that
I I don't understand I sometimes
struggle a bit with the meaning I've
been doing it now for six weeks with
Ukrainian to the point where I
understand a lot of what is said by
politicians I understand a lot of what I
read the number of new words is greatly
reduced granted my check in my Russian
helped me but I'm quite convinced that I
could go into and I'm going to do it the
languages that aren't related just to
demonstrate that it works
I've already started doing some polish
again without any reference to any
grammar book so where are the basics in
all of this well now that I've been 6
weeks or more with Ukrainian and now
that I have a sense for the language
I've been exposed to the language I've
read in the language I've listened to
the language I've got a bunch of words
in the language I start to kind of
understand a lot of what politicians are
saying on television for example so
today I went to my teacher self
Ukrainian which of course says
everything you need to speak read and
write is what it promises of course you
it doesn't have that but it it has some
dialogues and it has some explanation of
the structures and so I go in there now
and I read about the
you know verb conjugations and the
declensions and i discover some of the
things where ukrainian differs from
russian and pick up some key you know i
didn't even know how to say hello how
are you it didn't matter to me because I
was just exposing myself to the language
listening the interesting content I
didn't need hello how are you my name is
nice to meet you didn't need any of
those things
no I'm not sure I'm gonna need them
again I might forget them again but it's
fun now to go through it's so much
easier to absorb these basics these
things that that everyone gets at the
beginning and yet which are so difficult
to grasp and it seems like learning the
language is such an enormous task
because there's all these things to
remember
well now it's actually quite painless
and I go through and and you know and in
fact reviewing some of my grammar for
Ukrainian also helps me review some of
my grammar for Russian and remember you
have to review the basics over and over
and over again you don't match to the
basics the basics is something that you
pass over regularly and each time you do
so you pick up more of it and more of it
sticks and in doing this I'm picking up
some of those sort of words like you
know yet even because therefore however
nevertheless and all these other words
that I've been seeing and but now it's
kind of reinforcing to see them
presented systematically in in the text
like this but it's far more meaningful
for me now that I've had the exposure
and that's exactly what I'm gonna do
with Polish I'm gonna be moving
gradually into more and more polish and
after maybe a month or two I might go
and grab myself a teach yourself book
for Polish so that is how I recommend
dealing with the basics don't get hung
up with the basics at the beginning you
can kind of leave through them and give
yourself a sense roughly of how the
language works without trying to
remember any of it get in there with
some text read and listen I like doing
it on link obviously I'm not gonna
pretend I don't because they're words I
don't know I look up the meaning
gradually gets clearer and clearer I
find I have this very interesting
content that I can
the Internet in the case of Polish I
discovered that we have great content in
our polish library really good stuff put
there by I can't remember the name but
you'll find it there at someone who
creates content for Polish and has
agreed to allow us to use his stuff in
our library I know I'll be able to do
this for Dutch and then I'll try it
maybe for Turkish and but the approach
again will be the same exposure first
some familiarity with the language some
words possibly a brief Passover of the
you know leaving through the grammar but
without trying to learn it and then
after a couple of months really go back
and spend a day going through the basics
so the basics comes afterwards not
before according to me no I'm sure
there'll be some contrary points of view
thanks for listening bye for now